we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i got a
bunch of voicemails in the last 24 hours
accusing me of d platforming fellow
progressive host sam cedar like i don't
even understand what they're talking
about listen to this
what up DP longtime fan here i've been
listening to before you hit puberty was
listening to you when you came out that
you weren't gay quite sad about that
actually but I'm actually calling kind
of upset you deep platform my boy Sam
cedar and we need to figure out why my
platform so I'm hoping you're willing to
address that situation a D platform in
Sam cedar this is Jason from the 707 I
don't know what this guy's talking about
and here's another one hey David I don't
know if you saw the Sam cedar show today
but he totally talked about you he said
that you are by not showing his entire
clip you totally deep platformed him bro
right so like you should totally respond
to that and then we'll see what Sam has
to say to defend himself against your B
platforming keep up the fight yeah I
don't know I mean listen I I think that
this is maybe someone coming to tattle
to me about sam cedars response to to
someone else tattling about tattling or
the at this point it's like a endless it
it's like those Russian matryoshka dolls
I don't know how else to describe it I
don't know what is going on I don't know
anything about the platforming Sam cedar
I don't know what these people are
talking about but I will try to check
out that clip we've got a great bonus
show for you today we'll talk about the
new New York City tenant law that has
landlords very very fired up I also want
to talk about a division within the
Democratic Party about whether they
should give themselves the 2.6 percent
cost-of-living raise that they are due
in January and I also want to talk about
Ted Cruz apparently wants to team up
with Alexandria Acacio courts has to
make birth control available over the
counter but this is actually a stealth
free-market conservative move doesn't
mean we should oppose it if it's the
right
thing to make birth control available
over-the-counter without a prescription
then it should be but I do want to
explain to you what Ted Cruz's ulterior
motives are because they are exactly
what you would imagine them to be get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at WWE pakman.com or
become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show